2018 ist Chemnitz weltweit in den
Schlagzeilen weil rechtsextreme
hetzjagten auf Ausländer machen nachdem
ein Deutscher auf dem Stadtfest getötet
wurde von einem Flüchtling das Image als
Hort brauner Gesinnung kann Chemnitz nur
schwer abstreifen was hat sich seitdem
getan in der Stadt
Chemnitz wird 2025 europäische
Kulturhauptstadt ein Ort mit jeder Menge
freien Räumen mit jungen Menschen die
ihre Heimat aktiv mitgestalten wollen
Chemnitz hat einfach Potenzial es gibt
hier einfach ganz viel Platz für nicht
nur kreative Sachen und das ist ein sehr
schönes buntes miteinander hier ich will
mich zu Hause also ich will mit zu Hause
wir haben ganz netter Kollegen ganz
aufgeschlossener Kollegen ja wir
verstehen uns ganz gut deswegen komm ich
auch gerne zur Arbeit
sie alle gemeinsam haben dem
ramponierten Ruf der sächsischen
Großstadt den Kampf angesagt
wir sind im alternativen
Nachbarschaftsgarten Zieten August dem
Chemnitzer Stadtteil Sonnenberg im
Hinterhof Dreier stehen der
Gründerzeithäuser darf jeder
vorbeikommen kreativ sein chillen
was hast du dabei
von unserem anderen öko-betrieb ein paar
rote Beeten Salat grau genug
[Musik]
Carola köpferl kommt fast jeden Tag zum
Gärtnern
ich bin immer nicht so gut für
alternativ Gärten die ein bisschen
unorganisiert sind die musste im Winter
wieder rausnehmen und die vergessen
deswegen muss ich mehrmals zeigen neue
italienische die Doktoranden aus München
hierher der Sonnenberg ist für sie der
spannendste Stadtteil von Chemnitz
München genervt weil alles über Geld
geht ich bin kein besonders
unkapitalistischer Mensch aber es nervt
halt desto in München für so ein
gartenbräuchst du halt wieder irgendwo
Millionen du musst dich halt wieder mit
irgendeine Menschen streiten und
Chemnitz war so eine Zeit und ich glaube
ich ist noch wo die Menschen warten dass
es Leute gibt die einfach anpacken vor
der eigenen Haustür zwei Wochen noch in
Berlin ist alles zugebaut und hier
gibt's noch die Möglichkeit irgendwie
mit Leuten ins Gespräch zu kommen sie
haben Fläche na dann können wir die auch
irgendwie benutzen
freie Flächen und billigen Wohnraum das
bietet Chemnitz kreative Köpfe können
sich hier austoben die Wohnung sind
einfach mega geil also da bezahlt man
einen anderen Städten mindestens das
Doppelte zahlst du denn hier für deine
Wohnung für meine Wohnung mit 85
Quadratmetern Südwest Balkon
ungefähr ein riesen Wohnküche
lichtdurchflutet 655 € warm das ist so
billig einfach die billigste Großstadt
in Deutschland
selber anpacken das ist das Motto im
Nachbarschaftsgarten und deshalb haben
sie sich hier vor einem Jahr dann auch
noch eine Sauna gebaut seitdem wird
einmal die Woche angeheizt offen für
jedermann
es wird gut angenommen auf der einen
Seite die Sauna aber wir haben auch
immer Leute hier die einfach nur
Donnerstagabend herkommen um hier zu
sein um die Atmosphäre einfach
mitzunehmen und gar nicht in die Sauna
gehen wollen weil hier einfach
inzwischen echt immer bisschen Trubel
ist im Garten und ziemlich viel los
Gemeinschaft schaffen wo die
Gesellschaft auseinanderzubrechen droht
das ist der Anspruch nicht nur hier im
Nachbarschaftsgarten überall in Chemnitz
Zeichen einer zerbrochenen Welt hier im
alten schleifmaschinenwerk arbeiteten
bis zur Wende 1500 Menschen dann gingen
die Lichter aus nun stellt ein
Investoren Trio 20 Millionen Euro bereit
um einen kreativen Mikrokosmos zu
schaffen für Start-ups Künstler
Unternehmen mit Büros Lounges und
Fitnessstudio das ist super wichtig für
Chemnitz das einfachste leeren Räume
genutzt werden dass die belebt werden
dass auch das Stadtbild sich ein
bisschen ein Stück weit verändert
besonders in Richtung 2025 wenn ihr so
viele Menschen nach Chemnitz kommen
werden um diese Kulturhauptstadt zu
erleben
Basketball Ikone und Ex-Nationalspieler
malte Ziegenhagen freut sich vor allem
auf den geplanten Basketballkorb hoch
oben auf der Dachterrasse
du wirst das von der Straße schon sehen
können es ist eine der einzigen Plätze
in Deutschland die auf dem Dach stehen
ja es gibt irgendwie noch ein zwei
andere Beispiele aber nie die kommen die
nicht gleich also wir werden uns hier
Mühe geben und neues Highlight für
candle schaffen die Projektleiter haben
sich viel vorgenommen schon in einem
Jahr soll Eröffnung sein und klar eine
Bar über den Dächern der Stadt darf
natürlich auch nicht fehlen wenn man
schon verschiedene Welten
zusammenbringen möchte aus Unternehmern
Initiatoren und auch Leute aus der
Kreativwirtschaft dann ist doch die Bar
der beste Ort dafür man braucht den
Alkohol
[Gelächter]
Chemnitz will so gern hoch hinaus sich
nicht mehr verstecken müssen hinter den
anderen zwei großen Städten in Sachsen
hinter Leipzig und Dresden zeigen dass
es so viel mehr ist als rechtsextreme
Demonstranten
2018 beide dabei und für beide war es
ein Wendepunkt Ali schwor sich besser zu
integrieren als so mancher urkenntnisse
Jakob kämpft seitdem einen unermüdlichen
Kampf gegen rechte Strukturen in Sachsen
wir begleiten Jakob ein wenig durch die
Stadt hier am karl-marx-monument kam es
2018 zu den tagelangen rechtsextremen
Ausschreitungen Jakob sieht sich die
Bilder von damals an es sind
Erinnerungen die bleiben
wenige Meter neben uns ein zwei drei
Meter neben uns ist dann so ein Böller
explodiert den extremen Rechte aus der
Demonstration zu uns rübergeworfen
hatten und das war auch so ein Knall der
auf jeden Fall langfristig was mit mir
gemacht hat weil ich gemerkt habe das
sind nicht mehr einfach irgendwie
besorgte Bürger sondern das sind
gewaltbereite Menschen es ist der Moment
der den heute 21-Jährigen politisiert
hat über seine Erfahrungen seinen Kampf
gegen rechte Strukturen hat er ein Buch
geschrieben an diesem Abend liest er
daraus in einer kleinen Bar in Chemnitz
die Lage verschärft sich ich kenne
einige Menschen die es nicht wagen sich
in Städten wie Zwickau politisch zu
positionieren für viele Menschen wie
mich stellt sich am Ende ihrer Jugend
die Frage was anfangen mit seinem Leben
eine Zukunft in der sich ein
unermüdlicher Kampf gegen den
Pessimismus abzeichnet oder die Flucht
in Welt aufeinander stellte das
Schreiben sei für ihn eine Art
Selbsttherapie gewesen denn jakob ist
das Feindbild vieler Neonazis in seiner
Heimatstadt Zwickau mit ständigen
Bedrohungen spuckereien täglichen
Angriffen darüber berichtet er in seinen
Lesungen in Ost und West
schon den Eindruck dass man in
Westdeutschland eher noch die Augen
aufreißt und manchmal irgendwie die
Dinge die ich erzähle so zum ersten Mal
wird natürlich nicht immer aber oft ist
das irgendwie der Fall und in
Ostdeutschland gerade irgendwie im
ländlichen Raum merke ich immer wieder
dass die Dinge die ich erzähle sehr
viele andere Leute auch erzielen könnten
und die Erfahrungen da oft sehr ähnlich
sind
seit Jahren stellt sich Jakob immer
wieder Rechtsextremen in den Weg in
seiner Heimatstadt Zwickau gründet er
Fridays for future dritt den Grünen bei
engagiert sich überall wo es nötig ist
ich könnte mir auch vorstellen
irgendwann die Politik zu gehen und
aktiv Sachen zu verändern aber dann
vermutlich erstmal irgendwie Zwickauer
Stadtrat oder so
es braucht Mut sich als junger Mensch so
klar zu positionieren und es braucht
Rückhalt jakob ist in einem christlichen
Elternhaus in Zwickau aufgewachsen
Mutter und Vater unterstützen ihn
also die haben schon die elternlichen
Schutzreflexe manchmal die man halt so
hat wenn dann irgendwie ein Aufkleber
vom dritte Weg Neonazi gerade am
Briefkasten klebt aber insgesamt sind
die zum Glück sehr unterstützend und
liebevoll und ich habe mich da immer
unterstützt und geborgen gefühlt wofür
ich auch sehr dankbar bin weil ich
glaube das ist wirklich nicht
selbstverständlich
von einer Wochenzeitung wurde Jakob
springfeld zu einem der 100 wichtigsten
jungen Ostdeutschen gekürt als Stimme
der sächsischen Zivilgesellschaft will
er auch in Zukunft laut sein
Ali resaja aus Afghanistan lädt uns zu
sich nach Hause ein auf einen Tee aus
der alten Heimat die eigene Wohnung das
eigene Einkommen das macht den
24-Jährigen stolz
das ist eine sehr schönes Gefühl
ich habe da auch ein Kumpel gehabt also
sehr guten Kumpel wir haben uns sehr gut
verstanden aber dass man seinen eigene
sein seine eigene Wohnung hat und man
kann machen was man will und man hat
seine Freiheit in seiner Wohnung dass
seine wirklich ein schönes Gefühl über
das Mittelmeer kam er 2017 als
Flüchtling nach Deutschland Chemnitz ist
längst sein zweites Zuhause geworden bei
mir ist zum Glück international ich habe
Freunde aus Afghanistan ich habe Freunde
aus dem Iran ich habe viele deutsche
Freunde ich habe Freunde aus
afrikanischer Länder zum Beispiel
somalian
Eritrea und habe ich auch Freunde vom
Syrien Ertrag habe ich auch Freunde aus
Italien also auch aus Tschechien also
Internet
Ali kam mit dem festen Willen sich so
gut es geht zu integrieren er absolviert
unbezahlte Praktika macht eine
Ausbildung zum Industriemechaniker hat
nun bei Siemens in Chemnitz einen gut
bezahlten Job sein nächstes Ziel den
Meister machen
der Schlüssel dafür ist es auch die
Sprache also ich habe ganz von vorne
alles nach Deutschland kam habe ich
gemerkt ohne Sprache geht es überhaupt
nicht also du musst erst mal wirklich
die Sprache verstehen damit du im Leben
in Deutschland dann weiterkommst so und
dann habe ich auch zum Glück war ich
auch eine offener Mensch und dann bin
ich immer zu anderen Leute hingegangen
habe mit Leute angesprochen die Leute
angesprochen die Leute geredet und so
habe ich auch die Sprache immer immer
und immer verbesser
Ali Rezai hat Feierabend wir treffen ihn
an seiner Lieblingsstelle wieder hier
geht er oft Joggen Joggen typisch
deutsch und auch sonst macht er alles um
sich zu integrieren er arbeitet
ehrenamtlich in vielen Vereinen und
spielt Fußball als einziger Ausländer
unter lauter deutschen Chemnitzern doch
auch einer wie Ali bleibt von Rassismus
nicht verschont es kam ein Typ zu mir
der war ein bisschen besoffen
und der hat auch bisschen uns beleidigt
und so also so ein bisschen rassistisch
nach einer Woche als das passiert war
habe ich auch oder hatte ich auch immer
das Gefühl zum Beispiel als ich im
Dunkel gelaufen bin oder so dann habe
dann habe ich gemerkt oder hatte ich das
Gefühl dass jemand hinter mir läuft
obwohl niemand da war und nach ein zwei
Wochen war zum Glück ist das Gefühl dann
weg und dann habe ich auch komplett das
Vergessen
Rassismus bleibt ein großes Problem von
Chemnitz und hat wohl auch mit den
nachwende Wehen zu tun in dieser alten
sächsischen Industriestadt und nach der
Wende so vieles kaputt ging und die
Wunden noch immer nicht geheilt sind wo
die AFD stark und die Armut groß ist der
Stadtteil Sonnenberg gilt als Brennpunkt
mit hoher Kriminalität hohe
Arbeitslosigkeit und wenig
Zukunftschancen
einfach wenig Geld zur Verfügung und da
bleiben dann Angebote auf der Strecke
das heißt für Lebensmittel bei Kindern
die zu uns in den Kinderclub kommen das
ist am Nachmittag und dann bekommt die
manchmal sagte mal am Tag eine Nahrung
Don Bosco Sachsen hilft daher mit
mehreren Projekten auf dem Sonnenberg
fast täglich können Kinder in den
zirkusspirikini kommen um hier
aufgefangen zu werden
die kommen ja rein und die lernen im
Grunde luftartistik oder jonglieren oder
Einrad fahren aber im Endeffekt geht es
gar nicht darum dass ihr am Ende hier
ein Rad fahren können oder jonglieren
können es geht darum dass die ganz ganz
viele Kompetenzen dagegen beigelernte
Durchhaltevermögen Selbstwirksamkeit
Teamwork und so weiter ganz viele
Sozialkompetenzen die die ganz nebenbei
erwerben obwohl die hier
am Tuch hoch und runter klettern jetzt
haben wir was sehr schön
nee warte von vorne
den Kindern Halt geben und Struktur im
Alltag ein Hilfsangebot für diejenigen
schaffen die von Anfang an ein größeres
Päckchen zu tragen haben als andere und
wo
meist auch eine perspektiv und
Ziellosigkeit
in der Familie vorher herrscht und was
gibt es da besseres als plötzlich das
Ziel zu haben ich möchte mit dem Einrad
nur von der Wand bis zur nächsten oder
ich möchte diese fünf Meter 50 in
unserem Zirkuszelt einmal dort oben
ankommen und runter gucken
und damit haben sie ein Ziel gefunden
genau was in dem Moment nur unsere
Zeitgruppe ist aber in ein paar Jahren
bestimmt was viel größeres wird
nebenan werden Jugendliche startklar für
die Zukunft gemacht offener Treff für 18
bis 27-Jährige die bereits durch alle
Raster des Staates gefallen sind so wie
Andi 26 Jahre alt kaputte Familie
drogenhaft seit acht Jahren bekommt er
hier Hilfe
Sozialarbeiter als Familienersatz und
Lebensretter
auf jeden Fall dass er für Menschen
gerade wie mich ja da sind und nicht
irgendwie verstoßen oder Vorurteile
haben mir gegenüber
wo bist du
[Musik]
Jugendlichen werden hier in familiärer
Umgebung ganz niedrigschwellige Angebote
gemacht viele haben keinen festen
Wohnsitz haben psychische Erkrankungen
Drogenerfahrungen
alles mögliche Essen so keine Ahnung
also man kann sich einfach helfen lassen
und ich muss sagen also wirklich ich
besetzt die beste Maßnahmen
ich komme auch gerne hier das sind
Jugendliche mit vielfältigen hemmissen
wo einfach die Biografie vorher schief
gegangen ist und wir wollen den zeigen
so geht Leben und so geht erwachsen sein
und Verantwortung für sich tragen
glücklich sein
Hoffnung und Hoffnungslosigkeit Tür an
Tür das ist der Chemnitzer Sonnenberg
für zugezogene junge Leute gilt der
Stadtteil als kreativlabor wegen der
vielen leeren Häuser und dem vielen Raum
zum Ausprobieren
Katharina von Storch wohnt seit fünf
Jahren in Chemnitz die 27-Jährige wuchs
in Wiesbaden auf und fühlt sich nun in
Sachsen heimisch in Chemnitz ist mir
aufgefallen auch als Mensch der aus
einer anderen Stadt hergezogen ist dass
viele Menschen ihre Energie ihre
Freizeit dafür geben hier gemeinsames
aufzubauen was für die Stadt aufzubauen
also nicht um sich mit sich selbst zu
beschäftigen und sich selbst zu
optimieren und auch zu konsumieren
sondern eher statt zu den besseren Ort
zu machen und sich total inspirierend
und ich bin dankbar dass ich da ein Teil
von sein darf Kultur von unten von den
Menschen für die Menschen das ist das
was sie hier vorantreiben regelmäßig
holen Sie die Biertische raus am Späti
ein klein ein bisschen Berlin Feeling im
Sonnenberg Kiez Katharina und ihre
Mitstreiter innen planen Projekte für
die Stadt Lesungen Konzerte
Nachbarschaftshilfe denn diese Subkultur
ist es die die Kulturhauptstadt Chemnitz
prägen soll
das Ungesehene von außen ist nicht das
was womit Chemnitz nach außen strahlt
und womit Chemnitz nach außen wirkt es
ist erst es ist das was man erlebt wenn
man hier hinkommt wenn man mit den
Leuten spricht und das ist auch für
Chemnitz steht und auch weshalb wir mit
Kulturhauptstadt geworden sind und
Chemnitz sollte wohl auch nach 2018 die
Chance für eine Neuanfang bekommen um
rechten Strukturen die Stirn zu bieten
das ganze Kulturangebot was wir auch
hier schaffen und die ganzen Leute die
wir handeln die ganzen Künstler das geht
ja auch darum
ein gewisser Weise dagegen zu stehen und
gegen das rechte Milieu anzugehen was
ich hier ja etablieren wollte und genau
das soll ja nicht passieren
[Musik]
die kleine in die Band probt in einem
der unzähligen Hinterhöfe der Stadt in
Chemnitz wo so viel Raum für Kreativität
ist haben sich eine ganze Menge Bands
angesiedelt
Carlos geboren in Miami mit
südamerikanischen Wurzeln nun seit
Jahren in Sachsen weil hier noch was
geht wie er sagt
ich habe sieben Jahre lang in Frankfurt
versucht zuerst Musiker zu werden da war
der Staat einfach übersättigt schon mit
Musiker Chemnitz hat einfach Potenzial
es gibt hier einfach ganz viel Platz für
nicht nur kreative Sachen aber selbst
Geschäfte und so Chemnitz hat Platz und
Bedürfnis äh die Menschen wollen sowas
haben und das ist was es attraktiv macht
chris ist gebürtiger Chemnitzer
kennengelernt haben sich die beiden auf
der Straße als Carlos sein Glück noch
als Straßenmusiker probierte
und wenn man jemanden kennenlernt mit
dem man sich gut versteht und der
irgendwie cool ist dann lernt man
dadurch wieder jemand kennen und dann
lernt irgendwie wieder jemand kennen und
der kennt aber die andere Person also es
gibt ja ein relativ kleinen Kreis aber
wenn man diesen kreativen kleinen Kreis
drin ist dann ist man da echt gut
schnell aufgehoben
[Musik]
am Abend feiern ihr erstes Studioalbum
80 begeisterte Fans sind gekommen der
Club ist voll
das ist Subkultur made in Chemnitz
familiär nahbar und nicht perfekt aber
gerade deshalb von den Clubgängern heiß
geliebt
die kleine bandsgröße Bands auf kleiner
Bühne und trotzdem man sieht hier die
Party ist knackig voll schöne schönes
Ambiente schöne schöne Spiel also genau
das was man eigentlich sucht und was man
möchte das macht ja gerade aus das ist
hier so viele kleine Klubs gibt die
manchmal auch ein bisschen versteckt
sind jemand suchen muss die man kennen
muss und das glaube ich das was Chemnitz
ausmacht und was kann das auch sehr
sympathisch macht
genau so möchte sich Chemnitz 2025 als
Kulturhauptstadt ganz Europa
präsentieren mit kreativen Ideen mit
jungen Leuten die anpacken mit
Weltoffenheit und nahbarkeit